you ever seen LA
beast I mean which
one no the YouTuber have you seen him no
no really no oh my God we're going to
have fun right now okay we're about to
have fun this guy drinks 24,000 calories
worth of olive oil in one sitting he had
to have the thought before he started
like I could legitimately die from this
right this is what I was talking about
with Brian these types of thoughts are
are just hilarious to what he looks at
this bottle he goes I could maybe die
right now but I don't even know if he
thought that because if you did you
wouldn't do it
right maybe do you think you know like I
would think it's 24,000
calories that's how many days worth of
calories like 12 days or something yeah
that's half a month of food in one
sitting in like five minutes he does it
this is so this is the American way like
you have to think like your heart is
like I can't handle this or your liver
or something yeah but he just does it
this guy is built like wrecked Ralph too
just let it play in the background while
we're
talking I'm the
LA does he not look like wreck Ralph he
does yeah he does the best part is this
was like five this was like 10 years ago
or something yeah he still does this
[__] hasn't upgraded his production at
all yeah he's classic YouTube I love it
still in his garage still just does like
he just did like he just filled this
thing up with raw eggs and drank it sick
it was like 300 eggs or something like
that
sweet we'll watch that one after when
this guy dies they need to study his
internals like uh he's actually a
[__] beast
yeah calories in two or three
minutes
cheers 2 liters so just a whole soda
like
a is this
copyright oh yeah mute
it
okay if you're listening on audio this
is what it sounds
like he's
not he's not even really suffering that
much though no he's not actually he's
just kind of like he's housing this
thing
dude oh [__] oh
whoa I feel like two full sips of this
and we' be
like what what if it goes down really
smooth oh what if it just tastes like it
good go damn and he gets addicted to it
he's like can't stoping olive oil just
pumping it man nothing like a cold
nothing like a cold pint of olive oil
his teeth hard his teeth must feel so
crazy by the end of this dud what do you
think what do you think he [__] after
this it looked just like like that just
like that it just came straight out went
it slid through his body no it came out
like motor oil you know like just
waiting for it like like it's just like
like it's just gooping out like soap
it's just
black and his eyes are
bloodshot he just turning
purple yeah man oh God
keep playing it in the background keep
playing it I want to do
it so we should do this actually [__]
bodybuilding oh [__] oh [__] oh
[__] oh [__] happy birthday
bro don't like this is normal right like
don't Italians like take shots of olive
oil yeah they also put it in their
coffee yeah I've heard that before yeah
well Starbucks did that yeah what's the
average
Italy I'm JK I'm yeah this is why they
all nap in the
afternoon CU they know that's pain
right I don't
know [__] you're I don't know sorry I
just say some weird [__]
brother oh oh that's [__] gross
that's
[__] that's
rich that is Rich that like hit yeah
like the wrong place it feels unhealthy
oh my God you know what I mean what do
you choke on it or something yeah no it
like no it like went down the wrong
pipe like but doesn't it feel wrong I
that went in my lungs oh so
you're I'll just drown start
talking
yeah yeah like your brain is telling you
as you're doing that like you should no
arteries remember heart we need that
[__] yeah that's why my brain tried to
put it down the wrong pipe yeah get that
out of here oh we need wind to come up
we can need this out and he still went
the whole time we were talking still
going gagging
holy yeah it's too bad he put that um
key generator music in the background
it's probably royaltyfree I
bet oh my god
dude I mean he is the LA beast yeah and
I think so from the little research I
did on this guy I think he's
married and he still does this [__] so I
just think that's like it's a really
funny thought him like all right babe
I'm going to go film all right kids did
you pick up those eggs
yeah yeah he goes in the he goes in the
garage and drinks five 5,000 raw eggs
and then comes out and shits for like 5
hours yeah oh hell yeah 50 raw eggs
another giant beer glass for comparison
shut
up shut up and do
it I think he fails though on this one I
still got it we were about to find out
together oh boy there's there's CH okay
okay here we go here we go here we
go
[Music]
love this pensive music
yeah
dude is there anything funnier than
gags no
no the be roll
yeah
the gags over this music is [__]
awesome okay you know what I don't care
how long it
takes what's he what's he listening to
this song
yeah sounds like a it should be in the
background of like a montage or
something yeah this really efficient
editing yeah just
got some b-roll yeah just put it in the
corner that's a man cave right there is
it yeah yeah the GI and
[__] I'm making
progress I can't even
[__] I just need that was a good
one
what no
probably this the LA beast I'm I'm
bummed I think he failed wow right at
the
end wow
yeah so that's this is this is my new
YouTube Niche that I've been cheing out
this is your mark Queen yeah that's
really funny
yeah just best
gags gagging compilations oh I've seen
seen definitely seen some of those
before yeah oh
yeah